c'est non non
[Musique]
quoi de plus cruel que la perte d'un
être cher si ce n'est la perte de deux
êtres chers
or il arrive qu'au moment de nous rendre
aux obsèques de l'être cher
nous apprenions que nous venons de
gagner au loto ou vous que la france a
battu la belgique alors que vous faire
pour masquer notre joie au pied du
cercueil m plus simple rien de plus
simple grâce au mime et la sauce grâce à
ses deux fils invisibles et nous cachons
habilement pour nos poches
notre irrépressible hilarité se
transformera en un instant en une
tristesse poignante
regardez bien al'inverse imaginons que
le jour du mariage de notre fille
préférée
nous apprenions que la france a été
battue par la belgique ou encore que
nous avons perdus au loto et bien grâce
au mime et la sauce en inversant les
mouvements nous pourrons masquer notre
peine profonde comme ceci
[Musique]
etonnant non